okay good afternoon everyone welcome to
our third company of scholars lecture
for this academic year this is our
chance to hear from our most
distinguished and creative scholars and
our yield community and to hear about
the wonderful things they're doing
hopefully in a way that's accessible to
a broad range of interests in the room
today I am very pleased to have Nick
Christakis here who will tell us about
social networks which from my IE point
of view means we've come here together
in this room to find out why we're
together here in this room and if I read
some of his literature his publications
right it may turn out that we're all
genetically linked I'm not sure but I
think we might be so Nick is the solid
Goldman family professor of social and
natural science in the department of
sociology and he also has appointments
in the department of medicine ecology
and evolutionary biology and biomedical
engineering so this makes him a true
citizen of our campus I think he's
covered just about every school we have
maybe you need one in the law school in
my his background for a professor of
sociology is somewhat unusual after
graduating from Yale College he earned
both an MD and mph degree from Harvard
and then he went to upenn for his
residency and decided that the next
thing he needed was a PhD in sociology
which he earned at UPenn his first
faculty appointment was in the sociology
department at the University of Chicago
where he stayed for many years and rose
to the rank of Professor he then moved
to Harvard in 2001 and was there until
2013 when he joined the faculty at Yale
he's received numerous awards for his
innovative work in
election to the Institute of Medicine of
the national academy of science he
currently studies health and social
networks with a focus on how ill health
disability health behavior health care
and the end of life of a person
influences the social network around
that person and he's also co-director of
the Yale Institute for network science
welcome Thank You line thank you for
having me haha thank you very much for
that kind introduction and uh and thank
you again for having me so on most of
the work I'm going to be discussing
today is joint work I've done with my
close friend and collaborator James
Fowler who's at UCSD and I'd like to
start with a set of claims about human
sociality and how humans are connected
to each other briefly introduce some of
the work we've done on the evolutionary
biology of human social interactions to
set the stage for how a deeper
understanding of how humans are
connected and why they're connected then
permits us to design public health and
other interventions in a way that makes
the world better so how can we use a
deep understanding of human interactions
to intervene in the world to improve
diverse outcomes whether it's outcomes
related to health innovation cooperation
civic engagement security wealth
production and so forth because in fact
humans are embedded in social networks
and these networks obey very deep and
fundamental mathematical biological
psychological and sociological rules and
principles and taking this into account
gives us a chance to turbocharge
behavioral interventions such that is if
we can deliver them to particular
individuals in shrewd and tactical ways
we can actually lead to population level
change in all kinds of ways and in fact
what it can lead us to do is what I
would like to think of as a radical
shift in public health interventions so
we begin to think about not just how our
interventions affect the people to whom
we give our interventions but how our
interventions affect the people to whom
we do not give our interventions how
people's embeddedness and networks
allows us to take a broader perspective
a broader view on how it is that
manipulating or intervening in the
social world creates spillover and
cascade effects in fact we can use our
understanding of social network
structure for good to advance good in
diverse sorts of ways actually this is a
kind of a dual use
technology so during the Q&A we can also
talk about how you can use the same
ideas for bad but that's another topic
so I'm interested in real social
networks the kind we humans have been
making and embedding ourselves in for
tens of thousands probably hundreds of
thousands of years and not just the
recent online variety although I have
something to say about that as well so
here is a typical a network socio gram
every dot is a person every line and
it's hard to see the lines unfortunately
but every line between the two dots
represents a relationship between two
people and and what's interesting is is
that each of us inherits our relatives
but picks our friends and our spouse
picks our co-workers our neighbors to
some extent in each of those people to
whom we are connected in turn is doing
the same thing and as a result of that
we are symbol ourselves into this is
really ornate structure this is to my
eye the human analogy of ant colonies so
each person is making these choices on
an individual level but as a result we
give rise to a greater whole and we
proceed to live out our lives embedded
in particular locations within this
graph and your fate in life therefore
comes to depend not only on your own
attributes not only on your own decision
making your own biology your own
clinical circumstances your own
psychology and so forth but also on the
structure of the graph and where you are
in the network so trivially for instance
individuals that are located here are
going to be much more likely to get
communicable diseases that individuals
that are located here quite apart from
their immune system for instance how
their immunity system is performing or
individuals who lose their job and are
here are going to be more likely to be
able to find a new job than individuals
over here quite apart from their human
capital education or other attributes so
where you are in the graph can affect
your fate in all kinds of ways and to my
eye these kinds of networks are
intricate things of beauty and they are
so elaborate and so complex and so
ubiquitous in fact but and they have
such a particular structure that can be
defined mathematically that it has to be
the case that their structure and
function is not a coincidence that there
must be in my judgment in my opinion
some reason we form networks with this
particular structure that we can see
here and in fact whenever human social
networks have been mapped they always
look strikingly similar so in the upper
left we have about 56 high school
students and who are
they're friends in the upper right 105
college students and who are their
friends in the lower right or 400 people
drawn from a sample of 8 million people
using NSA type metadata on phone calls
for a whole nation you can map the
social interactions among all of these
individuals zoom in let's say on a group
of four hundred and see who's calling
who and you can define who's calling who
in diverse ways like very intense
frequent calling reciprocal calling so
forth to get a sense of the social
relationships between people and so
that's 400 people there and on the lower
left is a scientific co-authorship
Network scientists collaborating with
each other and all of these networks
look visually the same and in fact
mathematically can be quantified and
shown to be plausibly extremely similar
and this consistency raises the
possibility that we evolved to have
networks and have networks with a very
particular structure and our lab has
been amassing evidence that it is indeed
not a coincidence that we form networks
with particular properties and we've
been able to show or find suggestive
evidence for and evolutionary
significance to and heritability of
social network structure and function
and that phenomena like hemali for
instance the fact that we prefer the
company of people we resemble I mean ask
yourselves this it's widely known since
Plato at least that people prefer the
company of people they resemble and to
my eye most explanations for this
phenomena nowadays or until recently
have been relatively tautological so you
ask let's say psychologists why do
people prefer the company people they
resemble they say well people are more
comfortable in the presence of people
they resemble why are they more
comfortable than presence of people they
resemble because they resemble them it's
a kind of a circular argument it doesn't
in my judgment get to the heart of the
matter which is why why do we feel this
affinity for individuals that we
resemble and other properties of social
networks like peer influence you know
why why as a species do we events social
learning why are we affected by others
and there are many many thoughts that go
back quite a long time in this regard
but my general point is is that these
these thoroughgoing observations about
our social life that we prefer the
company of people we resemble that we're
influenced by them that people have a
taste for friendship for instance or ask
yourself this why do we have friends at
all I mean other species don't form
long-term non-reproductive unions to
other members of their speech
it's actually exceedingly rare in the
animal kingdom that we events this
property of having long-standing
friendships with specific identifiable
other individuals so I'm so all these
things we take for granted in large
measure I think have very fundamental
explanations and understanding those
explanations then which I'm only going
to briefly review today serves as a
predicate for designing interventions
that I think can be beneficial in
diverse sorts of ways and I guess the
most summary statement I would make
about the evolutionary role of networks
is that it must be the case I think at a
cross evolutionary time the benefits of
a connected life must outweigh the costs
so coming near other people exposes us
to certain risks of infection of
violence of misinformation and so forth
but also coming near them gives us
certain opportunities and the calculus
across time must be that it's beneficial
to us to connect with others in in
particular ways well one of the things
we did one initial paper we did a few
years ago looked at the so-called
heritability of network position and and
so one of the things and this sets the
stage for a number of other ideas will
be discussing today is a very basic sort
of primer on social network position so
here's a typical network of real people
and their friendships and the thing you
need to appreciate about this is that
there are different structural positions
within the graph so that for example
individual be has four connections these
are friendships among these people an
individual D has six connections and
this is known as the degree of a node
and people vary in their degrees some
people have four friends some people
have six friends some people have no
friends people know how many friends
they have but there are other attributes
of people's position within the graph
that they might not necessarily be able
to appreciate for instance consider
nodes c and d c has six friends and so
does d and if you talk to them this
might be the limit of their
understanding of their their social life
i have six friends you have six friends
but we with this bird's eye view can see
that there's a difference between the
two and i can cultivate this intuition
and you by asking you who would you
rather be if a deadly germ was spreading
through the network C or D D right if
the intuition that D is going to be less
likely to get whatever spreading and
less likely to get it early in the
course of the epidemic conversely who
would you rather be if a juicy piece of
gossip we're spreading through the
work see and this this can be quantified
mathematically it's the centrality of a
node and they're different kinds of ways
this can be done using eigenvector
centrality or between the centrality and
the same kind of mathematics is you is
at the core of Google's PageRank
algorithm that serves up pages the magic
of google is that when it's given a set
of pages that features a topic pages at
the top are the ones that are more like
c and less like d finally if you look at
nodes a and B a and B have both have
four connections but the difference
between the two is that the friend of a
friend of a's is back again a friend of
aids the friend of a friend of a's is
back again a friend of ace whereas the
friend of a friend of bees is not a
friend of bees so now imagine that you
were a prehistoric human and you were
going out to kill a mastodon and you
wanted to get a bunch of people together
to go kill the damn thing who would you
rather be do you think a or b hey want
to get your tight-knit group of friends
together to cooperate go out and kill
the mastodon but if the challenge was
not to kill the mastodon but rather to
find the mastodon you would rather be be
because the redundancy of information is
much higher in a than B do you know
where the mastodon is no do you know
where the mastodon is your friends
friend is your friend comes right back
to you whereas in the case of B you can
reach further into the graph to bring
back information for instance about the
location of predators or prey this is a
very stylized very quick set of toy
illustrations of some of the ideas but
the basic point is that different
positions within the network can be
quite are different and can be
quantified in various specific ways and
one study we did that was published now
five years ago looked at the extent to
which each of those three traits and
others which I'm not going into today
can are seen as heritable so on the
y-axis is the percent of the variance
that's explained or the heritability of
these traits and on the x-axis is these
three traits and on the far left is the
number of connections or the degree of a
node and what this slide says is that
forty six percent of the variation and
how many friends people have can be
explained by their genes now this is not
a shocking result people vary in their
taste for friendship some of us are shy
some people are gregarious that people
would have variation in this is not a
big surprise but we also found that
these higher-order properties of network
structure also seemed to vary and 47
of the transitivity which is that other
difference between a and B node can all
is also heritable and this is one of the
more bizarre results to come out of our
lab in the last few years because what
I've just told you is that if you have
Tom Dick and Harry in a room whether
dick is friends with Harry depends not
just on dicks genes or on Harry's genes
but on Tom's genes whether you two guys
are friends with each other depends on
her jeans how can that be well we think
the reason is that people vary in their
tendency to introduce their friends to
each other some people knit the network
around them together and some keep the
network separate and apart and have a
difference in this tendency and finally
even twenty nine percent of the
variation in how central you are in the
network can also be explained by your
genes so we've done more work in this
area but the general kind of summary I
would give is that this fundamental
reality of our desire for connection and
is consequently our susceptibility to
certain kinds of social influence it
turns out has always been with us and
where you are in this vast fabric of
humanity can depend in part on your
genes now if it's the case that network
structure has genetic antecedents and
evolutionary significance it begs the
question of how ancient this structure
is and whether we could document such
structural features in human populations
living in non modernized settings so our
fantasy here was well if you could go
back 10,000 years and look at humans in
the Pleistocene could you find evidence
that the networks they made were the
same as our networks guided as it were
by this sort of fundamental biology that
is within us obviously we can't do that
but we hit upon the idea of instead
mapping the social networks of a human
population that lives like we did 10,000
years ago specifically the haads a
hunter gatherers of tanzania this is one
of the last remaining hunter-gatherer
populations on the planet they they hunt
and they gather for their food they
sleep out under the stars they have very
limited material possessions to speak of
every six weeks they move around their
natural fertility population and and
there's 17 camps in Holland arranged
around Lake IOC about 300,000 square
kilometres so one of my postdocs who had
some experience there and Frank Marlow
one of the leading ethnographers of the
Hansa collaborated with us to do this
project and what we did is and they're
only about a thousand of them left only
about a thousand
hase left only about half of those are
adults and what we did is we made a
photographic census of all living adult
hansa a kind of haads of Facebook and we
took this these posters into the field
and and then we asked every adult odds
that we could find to identify their
friends in different sorts of ways and
when then we study this network and
other kinds of features of haads of life
in all kinds of ways but the bottom line
for today is that what we found is that
mathematically and visually hansa social
networks look just like ours so despite
the fact that in the intervening 10,000
years we've invented agriculture we've
invented cities we've invented telephony
the social networks that we make look
just like the social networks that the
haads are made in a very different kind
of evolutionarily relevant environment
in addition while we were there we got
the Hansa to play what is known as a
public goods game we got them to we
tested how cooperative they were how
willing they were to collaborate with
others by giving them honey sticks and
asking them whether they wanted to
donate honey sticks to their neighbors
and if the neighbors would reciprocate
in all kinds of ways I won't go into but
as a result we were able to quantify how
altruistic each respondent was and
that's shown by the dot size and color
here the red dots are the defectors that
really you know the lousy guys that take
advantage of their neighbors the yellow
dots are the kind sort of altruists here
and the orange dots are in between and
what we find is that hodzic
cooperativity clusters in the graph in
certain very specific in actually we
think highly relevant ways because it
turns out that it is much easier for
cooperation and other valuable phenomena
to emerge and be sustained when people
can control the structure of their
networks as we'll see in a little bit
and it turns out that that there's a
deep relationship between actually
between goodness and social networks so
so we then also while we were there
looking at this question of what is the
graph structure of the Hudson networks
we also evaluated certain ideas we had
about the role that network structure
might play in the in the collective
expression of desirable properties like
information flow immunity collective
immunity and and cooperation now a lot
of the work that we had done have done
which I'm not showing you today uses
observational methods where
study using statistical and econometrics
techniques different sorts of graphs but
we've also over the last few years begun
to do some experiments which is the main
focus of today's a talk because these
experiments have allowed us to get
around some of the difficult issues of
causal inference using observational
data but they also give us exquisite
control over some of the phenomena we
want to study and in particular we
become progressively more interested in
the pro-social functions of networks and
so our experiments also allow us to not
only address the methodological causal
inference but also to focus down on
certain specific things we're interested
in which is how networks are used for
good good ends this is one experiment
that we published a few years ago in
this example college students were
brought into the laboratory they were
strangers to each other they were given
a little bit of money that they could
play with and they were invited to
contribute the money and they were
randomly assigned into groups of four
and they could contribute the money to
the common good and if they did that the
researcher would multiply the money and
then the money would be divided across
all four individuals so the individual
pays a price but there's a net benefit
to the group from the point of view of
any given individual what they should do
is defect like sort of be a be a free
rider on every hope everyone else
cooperates and contribute to the common
good but they do nothing they'll make
the most money that way but of course if
everyone does that then the group you
have a tragedy the commons the group
collapses and of course the group does
best if everyone cooperates and
contributes to the collective good so
and that was the setup in this
experiment and then what would happen is
a bell would ring and people would be
randomly assigned to new partners and
then a bell would ring and they'd be
randomly assigned to new partners and so
forth and so on for six rounds and so
what we were able therefore to do is to
reconstruct social networks and explore
a topic which hadn't previously been
explored so what was interesting to us
here is not if I am kind to Lin does Lin
reciprocate the kindness a kind of
direct reciprocity nor which has been
widely studied and is actually also a
difficult topic nor were we interested
so much in the topic of indirect
reciprocity which is if I am kind to Lin
is Stephen than kind to me perhaps
Stephen sees I'm a kind kind of guy
expects me to reciprocate to him perhaps
he wants to reward me for my kindness to
Lin that's indirect reciprocity well we
were interested in is if I'm kind to
Lynn is she then kind to Stephen and is
stephen and kind to you is there a kind
of a spreading process in the network
such that we could show a kind of social
contagion of altruistic behavior here
experimentally and that's exactly what
we were able to show what we were able
to show is that if eleni is kind to
Lucas in period one Lucas is kind to
Erica in period 2 Erica's kind to jay in
period 3 and jay is kind to Brecon in
period four kind of geodesics spread of
altruism in this network and this is
another very bizarre result to come out
of our lab in the last few years because
what I've just told you is that how Jay
treats brecon depends on how eleni
treated Lucas even though neither Jane
or brecon ever interacted with a linear
Lucas here shown in an experimental
setting where we have X was it control
over the topology of the network and the
interactions between the individuals and
this geodesic spread of kindness is
different from the temporal persistence
of kindness such that if alania is kind
to Lucas in period one Lucas learns to
be kind and goes on to be kind to Erica
in period 2 and Lysander and period 3
and bamming period for and so forth in
fact if you fold back all the downstream
kindness accruing for every extra dollar
eleni gives Lucas the network functions
as a kind of matching grant doubling the
downstream benefits to the population at
conditional on the structure of the
graph here a structure we cause
experimentally but of course naturally
we make different kinds of structures so
pay it forward is real in this situation
yeah yeah I'm moving very fast I
apologize because this is sort of a
preamble believe it or not to where I
actually want to go today but yes what
you go ahead yeah kind to each other
without this so in this case in trollin
okay so in this case in this case what
we're doing is we're controlling the
sequence of interactions so it's not as
if I induce you to be very kind and him
counter factually to not be kind so
people behave naturally how their wants
to do but we control the sequence of
their interactions and examine if you
chose to be kind in the first period
what happens thereafter and if he chose
not to be kind in the first period what
happens thereafter both kindness and
unkindness spread but for various
reasons I don't wanna go into right now
kindness outstrips the spread of unkind
and the net result of which is that for
every extra dollar the first guy chooses
to give the network the ripple effects
that we discern so this is a study
trying to quantify and observe the
ripple effects so I could imagine
putting in a room with someone and
seeing how do you act are you nice or
not fine but then I could also ask well
gee what happens is he's nice or unkind
are how far does it spread in the graph
are there ripples and this was the
purpose of this study was to see those
ripples and quantify them other studies
I'll show you in a moment do other
manipulations to do the try to achieve
the following objectives say you're
unkind can I put you in a graph with a
structure and other features other
design features that make you kind can I
control your behavior by structurally
manipulating the nature of your
interactions and I'll show you some
experiments to that effect in a moment
other questions so using observational
and experimental methods we and others
have provided evidence that a variety of
behaviors and phenomena spread within
networks via social contagion so obesity
smoking drinking and drug use behavior
emotional states like happiness
loneliness depression I just showed you
one little experiment with altruism
crime andra papachristos here at Harvard
is doing some beautiful work on crime
and it's spread voting behavior I'll
show you that in just a moment
purchasing behavior and ideas so
different kinds of behaviors spread in
graphs via processes of social contagion
in fact people's attitudes decisions and
behaviors depend in quantifiable ways on
the attitudes decisions and behaviors of
others around them and in fact a key
idea about networks is that they magnify
whatever they are seated with networks
magnify whatever they are seated with
but they must be seated they don't on
their own sweet generous give rise to
phenomena some external force must
impinge which gets the process started
like an epidemic and then the network
takes over and makes more of whatever it
is the thing that you introduced into
the graph and in fact 2 r.i one of the
sort of deep purposes of networks is to
function as a kind of social magnifying
glass and we've begun to think about how
to exploit this magnification property
and other fundamental observations about
network structure in order to maximize
our ability to induce behavior change
with interventions in
populations by exploiting this
understanding of how networks form and
operate now to be clear were affected in
another way by networks as well it's not
just what's happening around us whether
the people around us are behaving
altruistically or gaining weight for
instance that matters the actual
structure of the network also matters so
think about these two objects that we
all studied in high school in high
school chemistry as we all know they're
both made of carbon but the difference
between the two is that on the left you
have graphite which is soft and dark and
on the right you have diamond which is
hard and clear and this originates in
the difference to how the carbon atoms
are connected to each other you take the
carbon atoms and you connect them one
way you get graphite which is soft and
dark connect them another way you get
diamond which is hard and clear and
there are two key ideas hear about these
allotropes of carbon first these
properties of softness and darkness and
hardness and clearness are not
properties of the carbon atoms their
properties of the collection of carbon
atoms and second which properties you
get depends on how you connect the
carbon atoms to each other connect them
one way you get one set of properties
connect them another way you get a
different set of properties and
similarly the pattern of our connections
in social networks can give the group
properties that are not present within
the individuals properties which can
very conditional on how you connect the
same human beings to each other connect
them one way one set of properties
connect them another way different set
of properties it's the ties between
people that make the whole greater than
the sum of its parts and new properties
can emerge because of the connections
because of the ties between people and
not necessarily because of the people
themselves so it's not just what's
happening in the people around us that
matters it's the structure of the graph
that can also matter now these sorts of
observations suggest to broadway's to
intervene in networks for good to
enhance a public health and public
policy in a variety of ways and the two
broadway's are to manipulate connection
to change the structure of the graph who
knows who to experiment or manipulate
the topology or to manipulate contagion
given a certain structure given a
pattern of interactions between people
who do you target let's say with
information or if you're a terrorist who
do you infect so that you get the
maximum bang like which one
should you infect to really infect the
whole population this would be a kind of
contagion intervention given a
particular structure and there's
expanding science in both areas so I'm
going to show you some experiments with
some applications to positive outcomes
that we and others have been doing now
this is one of my favorite illustrations
of this idea it takes a minute to set
this up but i think the payoff is really
worth it this was work done by a former
postdoc of mine while he was in our lab
using experimental platform that we
developed that allows us to recruit
people from around the world and come in
and participate in experiments of
varying duration in a virtual laboratory
real people in a virtual online lab and
in this situation what we did is we
created two different worlds in which
people would be dropped into a world on
the left and the world on the right in
both of these worlds there were
precisely 128 people and there were
multiple replicates of this but I'm just
speaking as if there were two worlds
there were many variants of there were
multiple replicates of each of these two
worlds in these of these two worlds or
128 people and in each of these worlds
every single person is connected to
precisely six other people so for
example here this yellow dot is
connected to these six read people and
here this yellow dot is connected to
these six red dots over here and if you
talk to people in these worlds I would
say to you how many people in your world
128 how many in your 128 how many
friends do you have six how many friends
do you have six how many friends your
friends have they all have six friends
ditto for you and yet the structure of
the network is completely different and
we with this bird's-eye view can now see
that the structure is different and the
question is does this structure affect
what happens to the group net of the
individuals now it used to be thought so
if I asked you let's say you can infect
this individual here with a germ or this
individual do you have intuitions into
in which of these worlds the pathogen
will spread more rapidly and more
completely the the left network or the
right network the left network yeah
because in the first time step the
yellow dot infects the six red dots and
the next time step it infects all the
other dots that he knows the network
flushes you get the whole population is
if vinson the epidemic whereas on the
right the epidemic has to spread in a
very plotting way slowly across the
graph before it reaches the others
and the same kind of thing of course
happens with information spread so the
dynamics of information flow would be
better in the left and on the right and
it used to be thought that everything
spread better in random networks than in
neighborhood networks but it turns out
that only things that spread by
so-called simple contagion spread better
in random networks than in neighborhood
networks things that spread by so-called
complex contagion spread better in
networks with the structure on the right
for example consider the idea of smoking
cessation imagine these are smokers on
an online site where we're trying to get
people to quit smoking and you persuade
the yellow dot to quit smoking here on
the left hand side this guy might have
some weak effect on these six
individuals but each of those
individuals is now surrounded by other
smokers so his ability to manifest the
behavior to which he's just been exposed
is attenuated by the presence nearby of
other people who are still smokers
whereas here this individual effects
these six people and it creates a
frontier where each of these people on
the frontier is connected to two three
four five or six other people who have
just quit smoking so smoking cessation
spreads like a wave in the network on
the right but extinguishes in the left
same with cooperation if you persuade
this guy to be cooperative he might have
some weak effect on these guys but
they're all surrounded by defectors who
take advantage of them whereas here you
can get a kind of cooperative wave that
spreads through the graph and
furthermore to cultivate an intuition in
you about the difference between these
two I could show you that you can
convert this graph to this graph by
manipulating a single parameter for
example imagine you cut these two ties
and those two ties and rewired the two
ties across creating a shortcut across
the middle that actually preserves the
degree distribution everyone's still
connected to six people and so forth but
you should have the intuition that now
if the germ reaches here it can skip
right across to the other side and in
fact by repeatedly iteratively cutting
and pairs of ties and rewiring the
network at random eventually you convert
this graph to that graph so the two can
be manipulated in this fashion but the
point is is that different things spread
differently in the two networks so you
now could live in one of these two
worlds and the same individual in these
two worlds could have very different
fates in one world the world is
organized in a way that makes you quit
smoking and
and and be cooperative and be less
susceptible to infections or to the
spread of information and in the other
world it's precisely the opposite so
this group level property it's like the
carbon atoms it's like softness and
darkness and hardness and clearness the
social graph gives the group's
properties that transcend the individual
elements within the graph here shown
experimentally by manipulating the
connections and watching and seeing what
happens in ways I won't go elaborate
that what's done in this paper so this
would be a connection intervention i
could take for example a group of
engineers that work in a firm and say
how can i make these engineers more or
less inventive or i can take a group of
students and try to get them to quit
smoking or be nicer to each other how
can I manipulate their graph how can I
wire arrange their ties between them in
a fashion that makes them behave better
in different sorts of ways through a
manipulation that controls the topology
of the network another experiment that
we've done that we just published a
couple years ago looks at another kind
of regime where we manipulate connection
in this experiment we did the following
thing we took individuals and we drop
them into an urge us Ren you random
graph which was initiated by us so we we
specify using this sort of mathematical
process a graph a topology a structure
of the network and then we take people
and we drop them into specific locations
within the graph and we have them play a
public goods game with their neighbors
just the people around them like the
public goods game I described earlier
and here in this graph in this regime
the red dots are the defectors and the
blue dots are the co-operators and here
people are dropped into a graph where
they're stuck with the neighbors that we
picked and they can in the first round
they cooperate or defect and what we
find across time in a world in which
people have no control over their social
ties is that cooperation disappears from
the system you're initially a cooperator
you're stuck with all these defectors
you say to hell with that and you switch
to defection yourself so by the end
everyone becomes a defector cooperation
is not sustained in a network which has
this topological regime on the bottom
and this was a result previously
theorized by many others and
experimentally shown by many others in
the
fast so we replicate that result but
then on the top we add a wrinkle in the
top we give people an additional option
so not only can they choose whether to
cooperate or defect but at every time
step we give them the opportunity to cut
ties to people who are defectors and to
form ties to people who are co-operators
actually they could also form ties the
defectors if they want it we don't
specify but we give them a little
control over their social structure and
in this type of a world we find that
cooperation persists in a world in which
we give people not only the ability to
reciprocate not only two events
behavioral reciprocity but also to
events tie reciprocity where they can
manipulate the structure of their
network we can create a world in which
people behave better so I can take you
guys and by specifying one set of rules
of interaction make you mean sons of
[ __ ] to each other or I can take you
guys and specify a different rule of
interaction I can make the same people
kind and nice to each other by
controlling not who you are but how you
interact with each other here's shown
experimentally in subsequent experiments
that I'm not going to present today we
explored the parameter space we sought
we explored how much rewiring is optimal
to create optimal cooperation in social
groups based on some theory of that
other people have done that suggests
that actually it should be parabolic
that there's a too much rewiring and too
little rewiring and that it's the middle
range of rewiring the middle range of
social mutability that optimizes
cooperation in human groups yeah so this
shows in this particular experiment we
had for the role I don't know a couple
thousand subjects in this experiment we
had four different treatments this is
the fraction of cooperative players at
the beginning here's the round of
gameplay this is sort of time over an
hour so on the one on the x-axis here is
the fixed network in green everyone
starts at around sixty percent
cooperation and over time the Green Line
shows a decline in cooperation and here
I showed you the so-called fluid dynamic
situation in which people are allowed
some dynamism in their network and
cooperation persists across time and we
explored how much dynamism was needed
also allowing a viscous dynamic a
situation and then cooperation
disappears if there's not enough of
fluidity in the social ties
so those are a couple of experiments
illustrating how you can manipulate the
wiring the topology of a network and get
groups to behave differently in
desirable ways let me show you a couple
of experiments is it any questions so
far yeah yeah so we had a number of ways
of doing that the gist of it was we the
mechanics were at any given round the
computer did an inventory of all
existing ties picked in the in the fluid
dynamic a simple random sample of thirty
percent of the ties whether they were of
all possible ties so there were you know
twenty people so they're 20 times 19 /
two possible ties some of which exist
some of which do not so they're couplets
on either side of those ties and then
with thirty percent probability couplets
that were joined one person was chosen
at random and asked you want to cut the
tie and couplets that didn't exist one
person was chosen to random and said you
want to form a tie and so that at every
round that what was what happened and
then in subsequent experiments we
manipulated whether it was ten percent
or 20 or 30 or hundred percent of the
ties were up for grabs at any given time
other questions so this is another set
of experiments in which now we are kind
of this is our sort of a more public
healthy kind of work we're doing so
imagine now for example that that you
have this is a paradigmatic example that
you have sets of villages in the
developing world and you go and you map
the networks of these villages so you
have the village on the left and the
village on the right and then and then
you you choose six people at random in
this right hand village the yellow dots
and you target them for a public health
intervention you know clean water
intervention or a polio vaccination
intervention and the conventional public
health point of view on this topic is
that you give these people the
intervention and you come back a year
later and you see what fraction of the
six people adopted the intervention
maybe three of the six adopted the
intervention but my interest our
interest is not so much in whether the
people to whom you gave the intervention
responded but rather what did all the
other people in the village do when you
gave these six people the intervention
so maybe six of these three people were
given the intervention three adopted but
they recruited
they're friends total of six people in
this village events the desirable public
health intervention whereas in the
control village that didn't get the
intervention perhaps by secular change
two people adopted this new clean water
practice or whatever it is so the
difference between six and two gives you
an estimate of the pure pure effects
under control in this situation but with
this sort of paradigm now we can begin
to imagine kind of more inventive ways
of choosing these six people maybe
instead of picking them at random we
might pick six central people six people
that have these these particular
attributes of being in a structurally
influential we might imagine location
within the graph now perhaps of these
six people again three of them might
adopt but they might recruit 30 of their
friends and on the left again two in the
control village same villages same
number of people same intervention 10
times the impact because now we've
picked individuals who are structurally
influential it's not what's important to
us in this case is not attributes of the
individuals if they're tall or short or
rich or poor but where they are in the
graph that we need to define and then
pick them and target them using
algorithms that people like Dan Spielman
and others at ian's are inventing so we
take some of that technology and we say
okay what does the mathematics of
networks tell us about who should have
the biggest impact if we were going to
rationally target individuals in the
network and there's another way that
this could be done because I'm one of
the one of our interest is we don't want
to just invent research tools for
understanding how to change population
behavior we want to invent tools that
people could actually use in the real
life developing world settings and so
mapping networks is expensive and
time-consuming so we would ideally like
a way of identifying structurally
influential individuals without having
to map the network especially if mapping
is not feasible in particular also
because mapping is not scalable so the
question is can we identify structurally
influential people without having to map
the network of the whole population it
turns out that there is a mathematical
fact about social networks that's known
as the friendship paradox that can be
summarized by the observation that your
friends have more friends than you do
did you know this your friends have more
friends than you do actually your sexual
partners have more
partners in you do too and your and your
co-authors have more co-authors than you
do and this is just a general property
of social networks the average person in
a graph has new friends but the average
friend of the average person has mu plus
the variance divided by mu friends so if
there's heterogeneity and degree if
people vary in the number of friends
they have the average person has the
average number of friends but the
average friend of a rich person has a
higher number and in the limiting
condition you can imagine that if
everyone had the same number of friends
then your friends would have as many
friends as you do and if there is a lot
of extreme skewness to the distribution
there might be one person who has many
friends and that also illustrates the
point for instance imagine that there is
a party host that has a party and has a
hundred friends and invites all of them
to the party and each of those people
have no friends at 101 people in the
room and now you sample from those
people and you ask them who is your
friend 100 people would name their party
host and that party host has a hundred
friends so for a hundred of the people
in this extremely skewed distribution
their friends would have more friends
than they did only when you picked a
party host with their friend have fewer
friends than they do so on average your
friends would have more friends than you
do I can furthermore cultivate this
intuition by asking you to consider the
edge conditions so for instance look at
the people on the periphery of the
network this person has only one friend
that's why they're on the edge but by
construction that friend must have more
friends than they do must have two
friends so everyone on the edge has more
Fred their friends have more friends
than they do and in fact that same
intuition holds all the way through the
graph that on average if you pick the
yellow dots at random and ask them to
nominate their friends their friends
will have more friends than they do and
the reason this is extraordinarily
useful and valuable is that you can take
this idea and then identify structurally
influential people without mapping the
graph you pick people at random in the
population ask them to nominate their
friends and you give the treatment to
the friend of the random people not to
the people that you picked themselves so
we use this idea as well in the
experiment I'm about to show you because
we've been doing field experiments of
network targeting in diverse locations
around the world in Honduras site where
we send about a half dozen Yale ease or
more about ATL is this past summer in
our site in in
PIRA and Honduras with a vitamin and
water purification intervention in
Uganda with HIV treatment in India we
just finished a project on polio
treatment online I showed you some
experiments and we've also been doing
some work on diffusion of innovation in
physician networks this is the region
where we work in Honduras it's a very
poor about two dollars a day population
Highland Honduras it's a coffee growing
region there are these little compact
villages that have an average of two or
three hundred people that live in them
and they're separated one village from
another it looks like this and what we
did is we map the networks for 32
villages in this area right now we're
also beginning to do a project where
we're mapping 160 villages in a
different area of under us and we map
these villages and then what we did is
we did a randomized trial in which we
took one third of the villages and we
picked five percent of the people in
each of those villages and gave them a
couple of intro public health
interventions so clean water chlorine
intervention and a multivitamin
intervention in another third of the
villages we picked five percent of the
people who had the highest in degree
with the most friends and in a third
third of the villages we picked five
percent of the people using the
friendship paradox idea so we pick
people at random and then we for each
person we picked at random we went one
step at random in the graph and picked
that individual instead and then to all
those five percent in each village we
delivered a public health intervention
and our question was can we move a whole
village and not just individuals to
change their behavior given a budget
constraint who do we target who creates
the most externalities for behavior
change so if we get if you put all our
money and getting these five percent of
people to to do something better can we
change attitudes towards latrine
adoption in India or polio vaccination
in Pakistan or or HIV treatment in
Uganda like how do we get people to
change their minds about something by
picking individuals not on their own
attributes but but where they are in the
graph so this illustrates two of the
targeting algorithms in one village so
for example the not the the indegree
targets look like they're in degree
either more to the center the yellow
targets and the random targets here are
shown in orange
and here's one of my graduate students
Allison Huang in the red cap delivering
the intervention this was two or three
years ago now this is the clorox
intervention and here are the results of
the study here on the y-axis is the
proportion adopting the Clean Water
intervention and the colored lines
indicate and on the x-axis and I'm sorry
on the x axis is time since targeting
and what we find is is that there's no
difference by targeting algorithm for
the chlorine intervention but by the
multivitamin intervention we find that
in degree targeting the nomination
targeting technique works the most so
you can start with a five percent
targeting and you get nearly seventy
five percent adoption of vitamin
practice over the course of a couple of
weeks using the nomination targeting
technique we have many similar results
which I won't go into and we have some
ideas as to why there's a difference
between these two types of interventions
this type of experimental work is still
at early days in public health and my
hope and expectation is that over the
coming decade as more and more people
try to use network methods to see how to
change behavior at scale we'll be able
to get more generalizable knowledge
about why some things work this way and
some don't so right now we think that
part of the reason for this has to do
with a complex and simple contagion idea
that vitamin interventions might spread
by simple contagion but changing the way
you clean your water might require
reinforcement for from those around you
so that there's not a lot of difference
not a lot of bang for the buck to be
gained by different targeting algorithms
in this type of a situation here's
another experiment that was done by
James Fowler many of you probably
unknown unbeknownst you may have
participated in this experiment this was
a randomized control trial the largest
ever done 61 million people in the
election four years ago were randomly
assigned if they were Facebook user on
Election Day four or five years and for
six years ago you were you were shown a
little banner on the top of your
Facebook page that said today is
election day find your polling place in
the US you can you can click here and
find your polling place and you can
click a button that says whether you
voted or not so far on that day and the
experimental manipulation involved
showing people whether or not their
friends had also clicked on that button
so the stim the experimental
manipulation was revealing to you did
your friends vote
not to try to see could we induce
cascades of civic mindedness of civic
engagement by manipulating the exposure
to information about whether someone's
people voted or not and an important
feature in this experiment is because
whether you vote or not is a public
record who you vote for is obviously not
public but whether you vote is many
millions of these people were also
linked to their actual real-life data so
we could link facebook click the I voted
button to did you actually vote to
actually get ground truth in this
situation and there's a lot of results
in this paper but the bottom line was
that this is the increase in the in the
number of validated votes because of the
direct effect of exposing the
individuals so let's say an extra fifty
thousand people voted as a result of
this experiment and they in turn
influenced their friends now we could
trace out the social contagion in the
experiment now experimentally by seeding
individuals with the intervention an
extra three hundred thousand people who
are close friends of those individuals
also voted there's actually a lot more
in this experiment but one of the things
that pleases me the most about this
experiment is this this was a scientific
experiment conducted on a single day
with a weak very weak stimulus just
showing people a little banner on their
Facebook page whether or not they voted
and that simple little experiment which
was not done to improve our civic
democracy got three hundred fifty
thousand extra people to turn out to the
polls on that day there's a scientist
doing a project that gets more Americans
hundreds of thousand more Americans to
go out and vote with a really trivial
intervention of just showing them did
your friends vote or not and many of you
probably have the experience of
traveling in a hotel and are probably
familiar with the famous results that
show that the way you're more likely to
recycle your towels is not by an
intervention that a little card in the
bathroom that says you know recycle your
towel you know keep using your towels
save the planet but actually a little
intervention that says 75% of previous
inhabitants of this room also you know
kept their towels for their whole stay
and actually that's very powerful people
you know keep their towels for this day
don't throw them on the ground now so we
can exploit these ideas to enhance the
response of behavioral interventions as
I've been saying both amongst the
untreated and among the treated we can
use it to deliberately create spill
overs and and to sort of reinforce the
spread amongst the untreated but we can
also use these ideas to reinforce the
behavior among the treated by trying to
get people who are doing something good
just be surrounded by other people who
are doing the same good thing to provide
for them to to keep doing it and
depending on how you do this we estimate
that often you can quadruple the return
on investment from public health
interventions by taking advantage of
this type of a network effect so people
are connected and so their health and
their behaviors are connected now how
much time do I have left I don't know
till when we go sure and when are we
supposed to end Oh around five okay
because I had been told 530 and that's
obviously wrong so um okay so I'm going
to skip another experimental result that
we had and I'm just going to close then
with one so I had one other experiment I
was going to show you which involved not
delivering information into the network
but extracting information from the
network using some of the ideas we've
been discussing but that'll be another
time so I'm going to close with one big
idea having to do with what it means
when we intervene in a social network
because I think such interventions
provide us with a way to manipulate
social capital and in order to
understand this we have to consider the
following idea what's the point of a
connected life how does it help us as
individuals and as a species and it
turns out that networks are a resource
that we can all use networks are a kind
of social capital now most people when
they think about capital think about
money but really capital is any stock of
resources any stock of resources that
can be put to productive use that you
could do something with and to further
key ideas about capital R that in order
to create capital you have to invest
skill and effort if to know something
and do something to produce capital and
second and much more interesting and
much more subtle as far as
concern is that in order to create
capital really what you have to do is
you have to make changes in a substance
that make it yield a higher rate of
return than it otherwise would but on
the deepest level what capital creation
is about is the transmutation of the
natural world that makes the transmuted
thing more productive than it was before
for example a farm is a stock of capital
you can take a forest you can invest
skill and effort you can transmute the
natural world and you get a farm and the
farm is more valuable than the forest
because you can do things with a farm
you couldn't do with the forest namely
grow fruits and vegetables and grains
and flowers for instance and that what
that's what makes it a reservoir of
wealth and a source of productive power
is this transmutation when you transform
of the forest into the fall into the
farm so improved land is a form of
capital or you can imagine taking this
tree and you invest skill and effort and
you transmute it into lumber and the
lumber is more valuable than the tree
because you can do things with a lumber
you couldn't do with a tree such as
invest still more skill and effort and
convert it to a violin and the violin is
more valuable than the lumber because
you can do things with a violin you
couldn't do with a lumber and at every
step of the way you invest skill and
effort you transmute the natural world
and you make something that is a stock
of productive power so capital is a
change that allows a substance to act in
new ways and this is part of what makes
it a store of wealth and a source of
productive power now a key innovation
took place in so with among social
scientists in the 1960s to begin to
think about human beings in this fashion
so you can take this dissolute former
graduate student of mine on the Left
who's a drunkard and you can invest
skill an effort and send him to
Alcoholics Anonymous and clean him up
and now he becomes more productive and
able to do things he wasn't previously
able to do or you can invest still more
skill and effort and give him a Yale or
actually here a Columbia education and
uh and you can make him still more
productive you can change his mind you
can work upon the neurons of his brain
and now he becomes a reservoir of wealth
you've transmuted the natural world and
you've imbued the transmuted object with
properties that didn't exist before and
this is what we mean by capital
production
well just like physical capital is
created by a change in the material
world and human capital by a change in
person's social capital in organizations
and companies and communities in fact in
our whole society is a change in the
relations among persons a change that
renders the group more productive and
capable of doing things it was not
previously able to do thank you very
much yeah your EP questions okay you
don't call people you want me to do
please okay Steve think I'd like to set
this up with the observation that humans
seem to have a very hard time
understanding the population level
consequences of individual decisions in
terms of vaccine antibiotic resistance
global warming extinctions of all
examples of population level
consequences of individual decisions but
that seems to be paradoxical if we have
been living in stable network since we
were hunter-gatherers why aren't our
minds better at intuiting the things
that you have to go out and create a big
complex research program to discover
okay so the question was if in fact it's
the case that you that humans have these
effects on others these externalities
that we've been discussing and if it's
the case that humans evolved a certain
cognitive equipment why doesn't our
cognitive equipment make us better able
to avoid the tragedy the commons I think
I think that's a very deep question and
I only have a partial answer to give
today and the partial answer was B would
be that the evolutionarily relevant
environment in which we evolved was
actually very constrained it was a
face-to-face community and the number of
people that we actually interacted with
was in a much smaller scale and that you
know Dunbar for example suggesting that
it's about a hundred fifty people you
look at the average size of overnight
camps in de anthropological literature
it's about 30 people these people all
knew each other that I believe those
people actually could see the
externalities and could see that they're
friends of friends were affected and
didn't have the reason to be aware of
the impact of their behavior on people
who were further away in the in the
geograph in the geodesic distance so I
think we have just enough
capacity to take into account the
externalities that affect the people
that are actually quite near us our
friends and maybe our friends are
friends and not enough cognitive
capacity to understand these other more
complex kinds of things so i think
that's that's part of the reason why we
are so bad at this and I think there's
been and I think there's been a
broadening I mean if you look at the
history of the world in the last hundred
years there's been a progressive
broadening of in the who counts as us
versus them right so initially it's just
you know my my little neighborhood
you're my family my neighborhood my
nation there's a globalisation movement
now the twenty percent I'm supposed to
care about unknown people on another
continent which was not was an alien
idea that people even 300 years ago
animals we're supposed to care about
animals in a way like you know we're
extending moral rights to animals
there's a progressive expansion of what
who are the we that we care about now
that is a kind of philosophical cultural
change that's still operating with the
kind of biological equipment that you
know is still back in the Pleistocene
but but still much respect that
equipment in some way so I think that's
part of the answer to your very deep
question is an incomplete answer I
apologize yeah over here Facebook study
yes your dog is entitled to meet that
research as well doings intervention for
entirely benign reasons even though the
users do not ask permission my question
has given the fact that the NSA and
people like that yes real access to
these networks how do we know they're
doing good yeah so the question has to
do with the thing I mentioned at the
beginning the dual use implications of
this so I didn't show you today some of
the work we've been doing after the
Fukushima disaster there was a lot of
misinformation that was spreading in
Japan on the internet about the rate
extent of the radiation damage and
everything else the Japanese government
became very concerned with how do we
facilitate the spread of true
information that's beneficial to people
as compared to false information that's
causing alarm and we've done some
experiments and there's I have a postdoc
in a graduate student in my lab right
now who's working on similar topics of
how to manipulate information flow in
networks to kind of open up the gates to
let good information spread and
am down the spread of bad information
and we've begun to get caused by you
know people in North authoritarian
countries that are very interested in
what we're doing but not for the reasons
I care about your they obviously would
be interested in like let's say
decreasing voting and and reducing the
spread but this problem is not specific
to the work we do or even to the social
sciences there's a long history famously
here at Yale with Arthur Dalton you know
in the some of you know this case it's a
very moving case of a man working a
plant biologist working on the
exploration of plant hormones who later
on discovers that his work had been used
to in as a key ingredient in Agent
Orange and of course nuclear energy is
another classic example so there are
dual uses for this the same ideas that I
presented today to get developing world
villages to adopt clean water can be
used by Amazon to sell you you know more
widgets so we're very mindful of this
you know we and you know there's also
the case of the weaponization of
influenza that was in the news a year or
so ago but I don't have a complete
answer for you I mean it it there's no I
wouldn't say that we should shut down
all research because some people could
use it for evil purposes but we're aware
that it can be exploited by the way that
experiment that the Facebook experiment
was entirely ethical it was approved by
the IRB it has no more than minimal risk
their studies like that that are done
all the time including studies that
involve administration of chemo
therapeutic agents actually yeah over
there um so I was struck by the
difference in the kinds of contagion
clear you have intervention the
multi-value intervention versus the
clorox intervention and you sort of
attributed to different kinds of
contagious yes i'm at identity like I
speculated I don't know my question was
well first as a sort of anecdote to what
do we couldn't have predicted that fact
the distinct outcomes are there two
interventions and sort of more generally
what do we do we understand what the
distinction is between those two types
of
agent so we can assess whether a certain
kind of process is going to percolate
through one of the three other so the
question had to do is there any way that
we can assess ex ante what kind of
processes are more likely to percolate
and that's also very deep question and
is on the frontier in my judgment right
now and I'm going to beg your permission
and I'm going to dress for two minutes
to tell you a little fable that I think
will illustrate this point it's a bit
off-color but I think I can do it
without offending anyone so now I have
your attention so imagine that you have
two islands in the Pacific and and there
are hundred people over here and a
hundred people over there and on this
island everyone is having sex with
everyone else it's a fully saturated
graph there are a hundred people hundred
times 99 / to sexual intercourse it's an
orgy okay and over here there are
hundred people and nobody's having sex
with anybody else they're all monks okay
it's a monastic environment now in
either of those two environments do you
have an epidemic of venereal diseases
they're fine these two worlds now a
little sailor washes up on shore and he
is sex with one person on this island or
one person on that island where do you
get the bigger epidemic the one where
everyone's having sex everyone else so
the structure of the graph is highly
relevant to the magnitude of the
epidemic but there's no epidemic unless
the network is seated the network must
be seated once it's seated the network
magnifies what is seated with with me so
far okay now imagine that you have two
different islands everyone is having sex
with everyone else everyone is having
sex with everyone else now in these two
islands and both of them but here
everyone is immunocompetent their immune
systems work here everyone is
immunocompromised their immune systems
do not work sailor washes up on the
shore where do you get the bigger
epidemic immunocompromised one so it's
not just enough to know about the
attributes of the graph you have to know
about the attributes of the individuals
in an egocentric covariance that
describe the people also are relevant
into whether you get a spreading process
in the graph okay now I'm going to tell
you a little piece of biology this may
be very useful to you in your future
life I don't know if you have sex with
someone who has active syphilis you've
got about a one in three chance of
contracting syphilis whereas if you have
sex with someone who has active HIV
you've got about a while I'm a physician
so I can say these things about one out
of five hundred chance of getting HIV
depending on the sexual act and a number
of other issues relating to viral
and stuff so so now you have a hundred
people everyone's sex with anyone else
everyone's immunocompetent 100 people
everyone's sex with everyone else
immunocompetent sailor washes up on
shore here he has syphilis here he has
HIV where do you get the bigger epidemic
syphilis so it's not just the graph it's
not just the people it's the thing
itself that also determines the
spreading dynamics now in the case of
microbiology we've got a hundred years
of knowledge that can shed light ex-ante
about the spread ability of these
pathogens how immunogenic are they how
big are they what do we know about
whether they express hydrophilic or
hydrophobic proteins on their surfaces
and so forth but in the case of things
like ideas or movies or public health
interventions we don't have that
knowledge yet we don't actually know how
spreadable things are and if you think
for instance about movies in other work
we've done we looked at the Cascade of
movie appeal in networks it's one thing
to talk about how good a movie is you
can form an opinion of whether it's a
good or bad movie but a distinct
attribute of the movie is whether you
inform your friends about it and you
might do that whether it's of this a
terrible movie or you might see a
trouble to move you not tell anyone
about it or this is a good movie and you
might tell them or not so the spread
ability of the pathogen is different
than the authority of the pathogen and
the spread ability of a movie is
different than the quality of the movie
and so ex ante I can't tell you what
these things do we can theorize and
there are some domains in which there is
such theory so we are an ex post
speculating about some of these things
did I answer your question sort of yeah
oh yes in the back yep abstract question
the last few slides about value we
talked about taking a forest making a
farm you have more value but you have
more readily been durable valve over
sort of
in case of forest learning now that
actually they have a lot of value it's
hard to measure and I don't think they
understand the translation good to me
that capital and social capital wonder
if there are easier form social capital
to measure and through intervention you
might lose less readily measurable forms
so i think if I've understood your
question correctly the concern is about
just to pick the farm example so I very
blithely stated that the farm was more
valuable than the forest but of course
it depends on what you're trying to do
if you want wood clearing the forest was
a really stupid thing so it depends on
your objective function it depends on
what is your objective like what are you
actually trying to achieve so the value
of the thing depends in part on what
you're trying to achieve and the same
thing happens with social networks if
I'm trying to arrange you guys in a
fashion that makes you optimal for the
spread of information like I'm saying
okay I need to arrange these people in a
way so that if I give a piece of
information to one person it's going to
quickly spread through everyone that's
great but then oops that's terrible if
pathogens are spreading that same
structure is actually really bad if now
I'm trying to prevent the spread of
pathogens so actually to specify what
type of social arrangement is optimal
requires you to specify what it is that
you're trying to achieve it's our
contention that across evolutionary time
there's been a kind of integration
across all of these things that you know
there's kind of a just right kind of an
arrangement of social arrangement that
is really good for the spread of
information but not so good that it
facilitates the spread of pathogens
that's really good for supporting
cooperation but not so good that it
reduces or increases redundancy of
information in the graph so that there's
a kind of balance we think that has been
achieved and so in the social capital
example if I've understood your question
the argument would be that that certain
types of arrangements are very good for
maximizing certain kinds of social
capital but might actually be horrible
from another point of view and the
example that comes to mind is Nazism in
in in the Second World War right the
same social networks that can serve the
purpose of getting us to reinforce
desirable properties can whip people
into a frenzy right and get people to
act in really horrible in violent ways
and that would be a kind of capital but
put two bad ends yes in the front room
yeah one of the issues in I forget which
experiment is indirect reciprocity
mm-hmm and so when we look at a brick
prostate easier to explain in
hunter-gatherer groups where is coming
from from Ken relationships mm-hmm when
we move out of there for example of
aragorn scientist right you know excited
that what made it possible for us to
have requests from strangers is believed
in Laurel gods who sort of men part of
our social network or looking over our
shoulder and so forth but it looks like
we do care about reciprocity from people
who are strangers yeah it's not just our
social finale yes do you have any
thoughts of blaming that we do we've
done some work on that first of all on
the god example I'm not an expert in
this area Master expiry God but but
there's an enormous literature of
perhaps you know it on certainly on the
philosophy of religion but also on the
history religion on the anthropology
religion on the biology religion one set
of ideas which I think might has a lot
of merit is a set of ideas that imagines
that are the emergence of a religious
sensibility in human beings was grafted
on to our sociality so imagine that that
that you and I share a belief in a deity
let's let's imagine the data is that
light over there but I don't know you if
you and I both believe in the same God
we've now become friends of a friend
right so you're now suddenly two degrees
removed from you via this other entity
this other node on the network so if you
imagine putting God in the network all
of a sudden everyone is connected to the
same God so now you can feel a kinship
to other people who believe in the same
deity as you do but that belief system
that kinship the utility of the religion
is grafted on to what used to be a kind
of social function which is that you and
I would be friends with each other so
this friendliness that we might feel
among strangers has been as a result of
religion has been actually grafted onto
a friendliness we might have felt not
among strangers originally so there are
bunch of people advancing of these ideas
uh a piece of your religion what was the
other thing you said there was something
else I wanted to say but I spaced on it
believe me more and more loads ah I
can't remember Oh friends yes so we've
been doing some work which I didn't show
you today that's looking at let me just
summarize it very quickly by just saying
that what our work has suggested is that
the people you choose as your friends
share more allelic variants with you are
more like you genetically then uh then
individuals you choose as not your
friends drawn from the same population
so what we think is happening this is
big speculation it's a big leap from the
data that we have and that we show is
that people it is believed by many and I
share that belief that human beings have
a kinship detector this has been shown
in other animals it's that evidence is
weaker in humans but i think we probably
do have the ability to distinguish kin
from non-kin but i think we have come to
apply that apparatus to the selection of
our friends so what happens when you go
out and pick from among a population of
strictly unrelated individuals who
should be your friend you tend to pick
people who actually share a lot of
genetic information in common with you
even though there are not your friends
and once you do that then all of the
apparatus for kin selection and
everything else can come into play
because from the point of view of a gene
if you help another human being who
shares that variant of that gene even
though that person is unrelated to you
that's all that matters that you're
advancing the propagation of that
variant independent of whether that
variant was acquired by that person by
descent because your relatives or
otherwise so we we have some very
speculative ideas and some evidence that
actually your way of choosing friends
and your ability to help your friends
who are even strictly unrelated is also
grafted on to a whole other set of ideas
quite independent of religion
yes actually and out now actually
there's dirt actually but but apropos of
that there are a number of possible
reasons we all share we all of us share
more genetic variants than chance part
of that may be because we were smart and
have been recruited to Yale so we have
those in common part of it may be
because we were not recruited by a
higher power to come here but rather we
sought this environment out so
independent of the agency of anyone else
we sought out this environment so
imagine that you have genetic variants
that make you an effective runner and
you go to a place where you find other
people who are running and that's the
people from whom you choose to be
friends with it shouldn't be a shocker
that you share genes in common with
those people and the third mechanism
might be the affirmative choice the
execution of choice from a group of
people who do spend time with so yes I
think Lynn is exactly right one more
question but I can tell you we have a
reception waiting for you in the common
room so you'll get a chance to ask all
the Iranian question last question you
could oh my you pick I can't see
anything but who's that person in the
middle there yes she he or she looks
like a younger person than the others
there we go I'm trying to bias towards
anyone who plausibly is a student I
can't really tell like culture or
material class yes
configure yes yes I'm so glad you
mentioned that thank you so much so I'm
often so the question was what about
things like like culture and class and
how they help determine many of the same
topics that I discussed today so I'm
often misunderstood when I talk about
this work as being a genetic determinist
I'm not I mean I think there's an
equally important role for culture so I
think there's a kind of as you must
surely are aware of you know this
endless debate between nature and
nurture and I just think any kind of
it's a silly dichotomy I mean they're
both important and and so what I've been
presenting today is the ways in which
our social structure depends on to the
extent we can ascertain our biology but
equally our social structure depends
hugely on our culture for example if you
go to Saudi Arabia you're not going to
find a lot of friendships between men
and women that's got nothing to do with
their biology of the people of Saudi
Arabia it's got everything in my opinion
to do with a culture of the people there
which prohibit those types of you know
of interactions so the social structure
there would be different than here but
but what I'm interested in and what I'm
one of the things that I'm interested in
is trying to get at what I would regard
to be sort of very deep and fundamental
aspects of human biology or are our
inheritance you know from our primate
forbearers that helped shape the kind of
social phenomena that we observe today
and in so doing I mean no disrespect to
the equally important cultural
explanations note that even when I
talked about the variance only forty-six
percent of the variance or forty seven
percent of variance and how many friends
you have was even upper limit was
determined by our genes the majority the
slight majority had to do with other
things how you were reared where you
were reared who your parents were your
class and all of those other phenomena
so they're not mutually exclusive did I
answer your question yeah calming room
which you go out and turn left it's just
home